we're heading into what's supposed to be
a very busy holiday weekend booking
websites rank las vegas as the top
destination for labor day weekend but
the cdc is warning unvaccinated people
to stay home hector mejia is live from
mccarran airport with the latest hector
good afternoon
hey there christian with the delta
variant going on the cdc issued that
warning asking unvaccinated people to
avoid traveling this labor day weekend
here at mccarran airport as usual we're
seeing the crowds out here a steady flow
of passengers that baggage claim most
said they're just here to have good f
they're just here to have a good time so
the question now is will people take the
cdc's advice experts tell us this is one
of those weekends that'll be hard to
make travel predictions for
aaa did not even make a projection for
labor day weekend but they'd still
expect a busy weekend
july closed out as the busiest month for
mccarran airport since the pandemic
started their latest numbers are from
july
counting 3.3 million passengers aaa
expects that travel rebound to extend
into labor day so we asked passengers
out here about their travel plans and
how they felt about flying right now
i don't think i'd feel comfortable if i
wasn't vaccinated but yeah being
vaccinated i feel like
we're a little bit more protected and
then obviously having mass and
everything helps well i'm here from
buffalo new york upstate next to canada
in niagara falls in rochester
and what brought me here today was the
bachelorette party
according to aaa nevada las vegas has
been the top hotel destination in the
west since the spring followed by
anaheim san diego los angeles and
sacramento when it comes to vegas hotel
bookings on aaa's website this past
august actually outpaced august of 2019
and we're telling you that just so you
can get an idea of the trends recently
and that's why aaa says they are
expecting a busy weekend even though
they did not release any projections as
far as the crowds out here it's not too
bad it's pretty slow right now but you
know once the afternoon kicks in and
more flyers come out here you might want
to give yourself some extra time if
you're planning to head out here to fly
out reporting live hector mejia 8 news
now back to you